[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est dans le 8ème
arrondissement de paris rue de monceau
on a rendez-vous d'ici
dix minutes à peu près un événement
samsung est à mon avis ça va être plutôt
cool donc là on est chez samsung dans un
showroom que samsung est un brillant
eric antoine salut antoine salut
aurélien alors pour elle rappelle moi
donc toi tu es assistant chef de produit
chez samsung tout à fait j'ai pas de
bêtises en smartphones on aujourd'hui
une nouveauté le galaxy à cette galaxie
à sète qui a été annoncé ce matin que tu
peux nous présenter voir un petit peu ce
que c'est ce qu'on peut faire avec tout
ça je vais me le prendre dans les mains
pour le présenter donc accès est à 7 qui
a été annoncée aujourd'hui qui fait
partie de ce que gamme de smartphones a
comme vous pouvez le voir la grosse
innovation qui arrive avec le galaxy s
est le triple capteurs vous avez le
premier capteur clip un capteur
principal 24 mégapixels avec une
ouverture 1.7
donc il va permettre la prise de lumière
en basse luminosité pour sublimer gros
photo vous allez avoir le deuxième
capteur qui est la mise au point direct
donc là on est sur un capteur à 5
mégapixels avec l'ouverture à 2.2 et
enfin la grosse nouveauté le troisième
capteurs qui est le grand angle on est
sur du 8 mégapixels on est sur une
ouverture à 2.4 pourquoi avoir mis la
crypte le module photo là dessus parce
que du coup on s'approche un peu de ce
qu'on trouve chez pivot oui l'idée du
perron avec en tout cas en triple module
même si pas forcément la même chose on
est vraiment sûr sur l'esprit grand
temps une vie nécessite finalement un
capteur à part entière moi aussi quel
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui a
disparu au centre sur le côté comme vous
pouvez le voir mon pouce donc juste ici
on est sur une parfaite ergonomie pour
déverrouiller son smartphone et boutons
volume sont aussi à droite cette fois ci
ils ont été déplacées ne sont plus à
gauche donc bouton de volume à droite
lecteur d'empreintes digitales et
boutons verrouiller déverrouiller puisse
commander aux tranches
hop je vous passe sur la tranche de
gauche on est sur le port double sim +
micro sd donc on est sur trois
emplacements
on va pouvoir bénéficier de la double
sim en plus de la carte micro sd le
stockage des téléphones en déshérence 64
giga d'accord extensible 512 giga avec
le port microsd cool
voilà déjà bon stockage
pour un pour un galaxy petite précision
puisqu'on parlait appareil photo
l'appareil frontale
donc là on est sur un appareil frontal
de 24 mégapixels et le flash pourquoi je
vous parle du flash parce que avec le
galaxy s est vous avez trois niveaux
d'intensité de flash sur le crucifix
exactement dans la caméra frontale hop
le flash trois niveaux d'intensité sur
le sa fille je vais vous faire une
petite démo on va dans l'appareil photo
salut rien salue d'ailleurs tu a
enclenché la photo en étant forcément la
manque quelqu'un devant et quand ça
marche toujours
l'intensité du flash hop je vais vous la
mettre en soit c'est le premier niveau
d'intensité
là on est sur le niveau 3 donc là je
veux nous rôle le plus gros donc vous
avez juste à coly c'est le niveau
d'intensité pour diminuer l'intensité du
clash génial voilà donc ça bien pratique
pour les selphy en boîte de nuit en
soirée plus mais ça fait bien plaisir en
selle fille vous allez avoir le focus
selphy comme vous pouvez le voir votre
portrait est bien mis en avant mais
derrière tout est flouté ses notes pour
triompher le mode portrait mais comme
tout simplement en mode self y vous
allez ajouter à cela le mode emo giller
imagine toujours là le chien le
classique donc les gif animés vous
pouvez envoyer à tous vos amis
yes le sati panorama qui était déjà ici
mais on est en panne ramaré la caméra
frontale sur l'appareil principal qu'est
ce qui va changer le mode optimisateur
de seine
c'est une intelligence artificielle qui
va reconnaître jusqu'à vingt scènes
différentes
quand je parle de celle je parle donc de
portraits de paysages de nourriture qui
me parle d'intelligence artificielle est
ce que ces bisbilles qui gère ça c'est
alors c'est pas bizzbee là on est
vraiment sur une intelligence
artificielle à un mode à part de
l'appareil photo hockey qui va juste que
fin qui va vraiment reconnaître est
saine mais qui va pas être qu'il va pas
dans la fonction comme bixby qui va vous
dire ce que c'est
de calories comme comme on connaît donc
là c'est vraiment le but c'est de
reconnaître la scène est pourquoi pour
sublimer la photo normalement il ya un
picto avec un portrait qui s'affiche
oui il ya un an plus tôt voilà donc là
en fait de téléphone a reconnu c'est un
peu de blanc sur blanc mais y'a un picto
donc là il reconnaît que c'est toi donc
ils vont clavier rieulay
qu'est ce qu'il va faire en si on prend
la photo en mode optimisateur de seine
il va reconnaître le portrait il va
sublimer il va corriger éventuellement
quelques défauts si j'en ai amélioré la
couleur ok saturer les couleurs pour
rendre quelque chose dans fait presque
comme s'il y avait un filtre qui a
amélioré la photo la mise au point
direct en mode caméra externe
vous pouvez régler le flou de
l'arrière-plan ok on entend le moins
très et derrière un bon gros flou un
sari qui permet de on peut régler
l'intensité la mettre au minimum et là
on est sûr très peu de flou en il n'y a
pas de fous du tout compris le mode
beauté toujours présent le mode trop
pour ceux qui aiment vraiment l'appareil
photo qui a envie d'avoir leurs propres
réglages le 3l capteurs dont je parlais
le grand angle est ici donc en mode
automatique vous allez avoir le picto
qui s'affiche
si vous appuyez dessus avoue passer en
grand angle là on est sur du 120 degrés
comme je disais tout à l'heure
d'accord vous pouvez clairement voir la
différence entre cette fois c'est le
grand-angle et langue normale pratique
pour intégrer tout le monde sur une
photo de famille même la belle mère qui
était essentielle sur le côté nous mieux
maintenant que le mettre dans la normale
sera dans toutes les photos non on est
sur un processeur octo core 2 points 2
sur un exynos 78 85 au clae sa part le
connaisseur ouais fiable de ramtha kwata
4 calé sur 4 gigas de ram giga de ram
sont 4 go de stockage 64 gigas octets
extensible
yes écran 6 pouces panoramique qui dit
panoramique dit suppression des touches
physiques suppression du logo en haut du
téléphone noël sur une surface
d'affichage qui prend quasiment tout le
téléphone un écran de 6 pouces super
amoled
moi j'ai super bowl est dis donc
les couleurs éclatantes et les noirs
profonds qu'en parle de noir profond on
parle donc de l'aide éteinte permet
aussi un gain d'autonomie hockey plutôt
d'avoir une led noir à lui mais on va
voir une led éteinte donc c'est pour ça
qu'on parle de noirs profonds la
question de résolution et pêche des plus
glauques et hook est super l'autonomie
ouais on est sûr d'une 3300 lien par ok
donc une batterie de notes huit dessins
pour la comparaison première donc une
autonomie vraiment remarquable pour un
brin galaxie à charge micro usb j'ai vu
recherche micro usb
tout à fait d'accord priziac toujours
plaisant quinze jours la marge aux
smartphones samsung
on n'a pas envie de le quitter les
utilisateurs sont bien là mon temps on
voulait encore peut pas le garder
toujours le président jacques j'en
profite pour dire que face a ajouté avec
la prise jack et donc les écouteurs la
technologie dolby atmos donc l'
optimisation du son la dispute le
produit phare disco sera dispo mi
octobre
ok pas de date fixe trop lentement mi
octobre cliquer au prix de sortie 349
euros on est sur un vrai rapport qualité
prix puisque et toute la démonstration
que je viens de vous faire un peu comme
se rendre compte que de la qualité de ce
galaxy à 7 en termes de positionnement
par rapport au reste de la gamme
on a eu le galaxy à 8 en début d'année
le 6 il ya pas longtemps là les recettes
je trouve que entre le a8 et le racisme
il ya forcément une différence mais
celui là il vient apporter vraiment une
grosse différence en termes de photos
que le capteur d'empreintes digitales
sur le côté c'est quoi l'adn de ce
produit il s'adresse à qui comme je peux
dire c'est vraiment l'appareil photo qui
va être mis en avant qui dit appareil
photo de prise de photos pour toute une
population jeune
il va vouloir envoyer plein de photos à
ses amis le côté et mogi envoyer les gif
animés l'intensité des flashs
ouais il aime bien prendre des photos en
soirée donc les populations souvent
jeunes ça ne veut pas dire que les
personnes plus âgées ne peuvent
reprendre
mais on est vraiment
on est vraiment focus sur un téléphone
il ya une vrai qu'un vrai apport dans la
caméra qui va avoir des fonctionnalités
en plus qui ont des pratiques les sous
types de population le stockage qui est
très grand l'autonomie qui est très
bonne remarquable donc ça c'est
finalement ça s'adresse à tout type de
profil merci beaucoup merci aurait un
très bel appareil on retrouvera mètres
plus haut possible et on le testeront
sander dit man vous ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire est-ce que cela
c'est qu'il vous fait un peu de l'oeil
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter et comment vous trouvez par
rapport au reste de la gamme samsung
vous marquez tout ça bien sûr en
commentaire et puis on en reparle et à
faire une seule chose c'est à vous
abonner et à rester connectés tels
accords rythme très bien
[Musique]
bien faire dans cette fissure je les
vois là non mon frigo samsung légales et
calmes et à l'intérieur un bon dieu mais
kershaw ce n est qu elle avait rompu
bon ça c'est très bien ça c'est le
nouveau frigo réfrigérateur et jonathan
podium américain de samsung est est ce
que tu as vu est-ce que tu avais bien
leur fait parce que tu as lu la
nouveauté c'est ça c'est le nouveau four
tu le tiens le tube tu as les deux
compartiments admirateurs différentes
je suis un expert du four à mention
monsieur mais surtout tout ce buzz
depuis quelques jours je vois ça comme
ça chez les cocos cru c'est magnifique
c'est magnifique ou pas c'est le
football est fait de toute bonté cours
[Musique]
oh